cycling as a sport as a hobby and as a
recreation it's just something that's
opened up to everybody and i think
that's one of the nice things about
dubai is that you find yourself becoming
a big family and dubai welcomes
everything like that
[Music]
the wind blowing and it's raising your
heart rate up
everything else just starts to calm down
you're just out there completely you on
your own there's a wash of calm that
just comes over you
[Music]
my name is mark beaumont and i'm an
endurance athlete
with the current world record for
cycling around the planet
seeking adventures and finding stories
is what i'm most passionate about
ever since i can remember i've had that
sense of curiosity about the world
this time i've come to dubai
today i'm meeting stuart to find out how
dubai's cycling community is growing
when you get out in the morning on the
alcatra cycle track and the sun rises
over the desert it's just that
palliative oranges and blues reflecting
through and it's so quiet and so serene
out there that i don't think that
there's many places on earth that are as
beautiful or as picturesque to go out
and ride as it is now to what it was
eight nine years ago an immense change
so now we have probably what is the most
iconic cycling route in the world
what a dream is a bike rider saying like
can we build you a cycle track in the
desert seven eight years ago there was a
handful of us out here on elkhudra now
on a friday saturday morning i'd say the
thousands of people out there so what's
the plan from here so now we're gonna go
and find some hills out in uh hatta the
hajjar mountains go and see what uh the
hills in dubai look like superb let's do
it
[Music]
[Music]
do you see more and more riders out here
they tend to stick close to the city so
good because it is a nice different
challenge for people to come out to the
mountains you think you're going to be
the only one when you get here and yeah
good couple hundred riders out in the
group i'm used to the highlands of
scotland but these are certainly drier
rockier and at this time of day you can
kind of see the way the light starting
to change and sort of cast those deep
shadows
i think you're gonna have to take a big
deep breath now alley up
deep breath
[Music]
it's another world up from the desert
[Music]
do you also kind of find that
cycling gives people a different
perspective on dubai because a lot of
people if they've not been here or maybe
they've been on holiday we'll just
picture that there's so many things that
happen outside of the vibrant city that
is dubai your
your stones throw away from a hustling
bustle of
a vibrant city
stones throw away out into the desert to
go and cycle or up to hatta mountains to
to go and play in the mountains you know
the the lakes out on alcudra the cycle
track the the desert safaris the
the camping that goes out it's just an
amazing place to live superb nice crack
on
[Music]
year on year dubai changes insanely fast
the infrastructure the build certainly
when it comes to cycling i mean i've
seen it in my world as a professional
bike rider in the last 10 years that's
just exploded in popularity globally and
here in dubai it's been matched with the
building of cycle tracks and huge
investment and events popping up all
over the place i can see through
spending quality time with stuart he's
just passionate about the sport he loves
sharing that
to land here and see somebody who is so
ingrained in the culture and trying to
make a change to this great place to
ride
[Music]
you